[Music]
what is the health update how are you
doing I'm doing well I'm healing and
some pain and discomfort this evening
but I'm here I'm here to promote the
show and support it and we're
cancer-free we got it all out do we know
what well we are in remission yeah I
have to wait for a week or two for my
pathology reports to come back but as
far as I know the doctor said that she
removed everything that she found I'm
glad to hear that I was also glad to
hear about this other news can we see
that ring look at that he did good yeah
no he's a sweetie he's got good taste
and it's date night tonight he's here
how did you know he was the one cuz I
got butterflies again you know and he
made me smile and you know he's smart
we're contemporary as we understand each
other I am very impressed with who he is
as a person
I admire him and I think the feeling is
mutual
it looks mutual you guys look very much
in love when you were just closing on
the carpet just getting married in again
scare you at all of course of course it
says [ __ ] it or not my first go at it
didn't turn out that well but you know
what I believe in love and I liked
having a lifetime partner I like the
thought of growing old with someone have
we started wedding planning at all
thinking about it we've started but
we're we're going away together this
Christmas and I'm going to talk more and
my maid of honor is gonna be away with
that I'll see her get all the yeah
everything going
[Music]
you